partir d'allemagne pour la pologne c'est
l'annnonce de donald trump alors qu'il
recevait à la maison blanche son
homologue polonais andrezj duda nous
allons réunir nos forces en allemagne
certains rentreront à la maison d'autres
iront ailleurs mais la pologne sera l'un
de ses autres endroits ces autres
endroits en europe
aucun détail sur les chiffre n'a été
donné mais cette annonce intervient dans
un contexte de tension entre les états
unis l'allemagne
il y a quelques jours le président
américain avait évoqué la diminution des
troupes américaines basées en allemagne
de 52000 à 25 mille hommes reprochant
notamment à berlin des impayés dans sa
contribution à l'otan l'allemagne sont
des délinquants ce sont les délinquants
depuis des années ça fait des années
qu'ils ont des arriérés et ils doivent
des milliards de dollars à l'otan il
faut qu'il paie une présence américaine
en allemagne importante pour la sécurité
américaine et européenne avait déclaré
en réponse le lendemain le ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères
ce mercredi depuis les jardins de la
maison blanche le président polonais a
assuré qu'il n'avait pas demandé à
donald trump de transférer les troubles
dans son pays mais avoue lui avoir
demandé de ne pas retirer de soldats
américains d'europe